you know heart disease is right at the
top of the list among all causes of
death and I talk a lot about what to
avoid for heart problems and
cardiovascular disease but today we're
going to talk about what to eat to clean
out your arteries whether you already
have an existing heart problem or you
want to just prevent some things so I'm
going to talk about what to eat but I
think it's going to be important to also
cover what not to eat so I just want to
briefly talk about that and then get
right into exactly what you should eat
so that way you know why you should eat
certain things all right so where does
this heart problem actually start and
originate well it starts on the inside
of your artery there's a very uh thin
layer of cells in fact it's just a one
cell layer thickness inside your
arteries and it's called the endothelial
layer and it's permeable it allows
things to go back and forth and it lines
all your vascular system as well as the
lymphatic system and uh your kidneys are
connected to this so when you filter
blood to the kidneys you have this
little thin wall that helps to filter
things out as well as keep things in and
so this cell wall um actually has a lot
of different receptors for controlling
blood pressure uh there's hormonal
interactions there's a huge immune uh
part of these cells so whatever's in
your blood is going to affect that layer
I mean the obvious thing is like when
you smoke or drink those things those
toxins end up in your blood and it
actually influences that wall and I do
want to emphasize the word chronic
because you have people that
occasionally go off their plans right
but then you have people that
chronically do certain things right
they're chronically exposing their
arteries to whatever's in the smoke or
whatever's in their food or alcohol and
that really creates the big problem and
you also have as another aspect uh
stress can affect that cell layer and of
course sugar refined sugars especially
refined
carbohydrates even sometimes worse than
sugar even the gluten and Grains can
irritate that cell wall and another big
one is seed oils okay canola soy oil
corn oil um cotton seed oil so when the
inside layer of your arteries are
exposed to these things you induce
inflammation and that is really the
start of this Cascade of things where
your body starts triggering this healing
response where you get this Band-Aid
which includes proteins like fibrous
tissue uh they're called fibrin and then
you have a combination of cholesterol
and calcium so that's what makes up this
clot and there's really some good test
out there especially the coronary artery
calcification test uh the cic test I
would highly recommend to do that I had
it done you want it zero and that's a
really good predictor of mortality
another really good test is a heart rate
variability test uh there's a lot of
research on that uh which is a certain
devices that you can hook up to even
your finger or a band around your your
waist or your arm to pick up what's
happening with the the contraction and
relaxation of not just the heart but all
the vessels involved and from that test
you can tell what's happening with the
cardiovascular system uh it's really
good especially with a long-distance
Runners who look healthy but some of
them are not healthy maybe they're
overtraining or something and they have
inflammation going on in the arteries
which then can create a problem like a
heart attack after they reach the finish
line so you can't always go by how
someone looks on the outside um there's
certain tests that can pick up things on
the inside another really good test
would be to measure the small dense
particle size of your ldls right that's
a really good indicator of something
called oxidative LDL which is basically
is this protein carrier of certain fat
that has been exposed to certain things
and it's it's a bit pathogenic because
it can invade inside of that layer and
get deeper into the area and it can
create inflammation and it lingers
around longer than the other LDL called
the large buoyant which I don't want to
get too deep into that topic but you
just need to know that there's two types
of LDL and there's kind of one that is
more pathogenic and one that is uh not
as pathogenic you also have this other
bar marker which actually indicates a B
vitamin deficiency okay and that would
be homosysteine so that's another test
that could be done if homosysteine is
too high this means that you're
deficient certain B vitamins that are
necessary to protect uh the inside of
the artery and if you have high homo in
you can be at risk for heart attack and
stroke and for that you're going to need
natural uh forms of certain vitamins
like uh folate and also B6 and also B12
because here's the thing there is a
certain genetic problem that a lot of
people have and it's called
MTHFR and if you have a problem with
this this means that you can't convert
these synthetic versions of these
vitamins to the active form a lot of
people are deficient in that so then the
homoy level goes up and they're at risk
for a lot of problems so a simple
solution is just to consume more folate
not folic acid which is in a lot of the
enriched flour products enrich grains
they also put in energy drinks and they
put in supplements you want to stay away
from folic acid and then we have this
question of like how does the calcium
end up in the arteries well there's one
protein in the body that helps you keep
calcium from building up in the soft
tissues in the arteries and that protein
is controlled by vitamin K2 so part of
this list of foods are going to be heavy
in the vitamin K2 because we want to
keep the calcium out of the arteries
another really common deficiency that
creates a lot of problems in the
arteries because it's a real strong
protective thing for the inside of the
arteries is vitamin E so part of this
list it's also going to include vitamin
E and one food that really depletes your
vitamin E is the refined grains okay the
problem with grains is it's loaded with
gluten too and then you say well what if
I have gluten-free well then it's
refined so we have this higher sugar
this product that turns in the sugar
faster and we don't want sugar to end up
in the arteries nin is another really
important nutrient that is going to be
in these list of foods and of course
vitamin C is going to be in there as
well because that's a very important
antioxidant that can help decrease some
of the uh damage that you're exposed to
in the environment with the foods you
eat and other things so let's dive right
into the list okay number one is the
heavy on the omega-3 fatty acids that
would be of course salmon other fatty
fish sardines very very important and
there's one more thing too that I
consume on a regular basis and you
probably heard of cod liver oil but you
may have not heard of cod liver that's
right Cod Liver so here's an example of
it right here Cod Liver I don't know if
you can see that cod liver in the oil
and sometimes I crave it so I'll do this
you know maybe once or twice a week has
my protein Source it's bathed in this
omega3 fatty acid so I wouldn't drink
all that I I would just have the salmon
and maybe feed the oil to your your
animals like dogs for example they like
it but uh it's a lot of oil to consume
and sometimes I'll do sardines as well
and of course the sardines I do in olive
oil so that would be number two olive
oil olive oil has a lot of great
properties for the cardiovascular system
to help people prevent high blood
pressure it's a really good fat it's
loaded with heart healthy supportive
things for the endothelial cells and you
really want to make sure that it's extra
virgin olive oil from a location or farm
that really cares about their olive oil
that does a good job of producing it
compared to some of the olive oil that
you you take it's just so Bland it's not
even real and there's also a lot of fake
olive oil out there so make sure you
have the good stuff I like the stuff
from Italy but there's also great stuff
from Greece Spain France all over the
place place and number three dark leafy
green vegetables okay so you can put the
olive oil on that dark leafy green to
help extract these phytonutrients
because a lot of the phytonutrients in
Plants especially salad are fat cable
and the dark leafy green vegetables have
a good amount of vitamin C okay they
also are loaded with folate which is the
natural form of B9 and the dark leafy
green vegetables also has magnesium as
well as potassium okay in the next food
I'm recommend is the type of cheese that
you'll put on your salad now a lot of
people use the American version of this
called parmesan cheese right which is I
think by Craft from my viewpoint doesn't
even compare to the real stuff that um
they specialize in a certain part of
Italy to create this one type of cheese
which is loaded in vitamin K2 which is
really important in keeping that calcium
out of the artery and please excuse me
if I butcher the name of this but it's
called paragano and you can usually find
this at any store you you have to make
sure that you get the right kind because
a lot of times the regular parmesan
cheese that you get in America they have
this added ingredient called cellulose
which is from wood pulp kind of like a
filler like let me ask you this why
would you want to put a filler in this
cheese I will guarantee if you get the
real stuff from Italy they're not going
to put wood pulp in there okay in the
form of silos and I actually did a tour
of how they make this cheese and they
put a lot of care into this traditional
cheese it's dynamite on your salad so
you get all this vitamin K2 you add the
extra virgin olive oil on there and then
I also put on nutritional yeast okay
remember when I said unfortified right
you want to get the one that's not
fortified with anything synthetic if you
fortify it with natural vitamins fine
but not with synthetics like most
companies do but the point is that this
nutritional yeast has a good natural
form of B9 and the one that I recommend
which I'll put a link down below also
has the right form of B12 which is
methyl camine but it gives it a natural
boost of B vitamins including B1 for
stress and it also has a nice little
cheesy taste to it I love it so there's
another food that I'm going to add to
this list that's loaded with vitamin K2
and loaded with vitamin C in fact it is
the top food that I know of that has the
most vitamin C of anything and it's raw
sauerkraut so it's very important not to
buy sauerkraut in um a bottle that has
been pasteurized you want it raw but
sauerkraut is loaded with vitamin K2 too
and it's also a probiotic it's a preotic
and it also has a lot of vitamin C like
700 milligrams per cup the next heart
healthy food I'm going to recommend
almonds believe it or not are loaded
with magnesium and so is spinach and
also vitamin E but both of those are
loaded with oxalates so if you have
Cheese close to the meal okay you'll
have the calcium that will bind with the
oxalates and prevent that potential
irritation to your kidney or even a
kidney stone if someone is predisposed
to it all right the next food I'm going
to recommend is liver that's right now
you can do beef liver you can even do
this Cod Liver right it's liver or
chicken livers make sure they're quality
but I know you might disagree with me on
this point but just think about it if
you have a high quality liver product um
like a beef liver or whatever look what
you're getting you're getting pretty
much all the nutrients you can imagine I
mean almost every vitamin in there in
great quantities it has the folate which
is high in vegetables and it has vitamin
K2 so we're about to tell you the last
one and then I'm going to explain why
I'm telling you this okay um first of
all if you do a search on heart healthy
foods they will give you you know
vegetables fruits whole grains right
which we know is not very healthy from
my viewpoint and then they say stay away
from you know sugar junk food and then
they say red processed meat and that is
everywhere so they're including red meat
is being very dangerous to your heart
and and so they kind of lump in all this
meat together okay into one category but
hasn't man consume red meat for quite
some time haven't we evolved on red meat
I mean is that really the source of all
of our heart problems red meat really
and of course I'm talking about the
grass-fed I'm not talking about grain
fed and I know a lot of farmers in the
area and a lot of them use grains to
fatten the cattle because it makes the
meat marbleized and the same thing with
pigs and even horses right you give too
much grain to a horse or a pig they get
fat I mean what about humans why would
we want to recommend like 65% of our
carbohydrates being grained why why do
we want to make that push if you consume
grass-fed grass finished beef it's
leaner and it's healthier and I raised
my own beef and it's extremely healthy
for the heart it has has all of the B
vitamins I talked about including folate
and b6 and b12 it has iron people aren't
going to be allergic to it it's not
going to irritate your gut it's loaded
with glutamine which is good for
inflammation so I just want to talk a
little bit more about this red meat
because uh there's been an extensive
extensive very large credible study that
was done fairly recently that I want to
share with you and I actually found it
in an article uh from Time Magazine
titled eat less red meat scientists said
some believe that was bad advice so
check this out it says the evidence is
too weak to justify telling individuals
to eat less beef and pork according to
the new research the findings erode
public trust critics said which I'm
going to get to what why they're saying
that if there are health benefits from
eating less beef and pork they're small
the researchers concluded indeed the
advantages are so faint that they can be
discerned only when looking at large
populations the scientist said and are
not sufficient to tell individuals to
change their meat eating habits I mean
that's incredible because I mean look
what they're trying to push with this
red meat they're trying to get rid of
the cows uh you know mainly for
environmental thing but they throw in
there that it's bad for your health U
which is absolutely based on no real
evidence it's already they have been met
with Fierce criticism by public health
researchers the American Heart
Association the American Cancer Society
in Harvard ch and School of Public
Health and other groups some called for
the journals editors to delay
publication altogether in a statement
scientist at Harvard warned that the
conclusions harm The credibility of
nutrition science and a road public
trust in scientific research now let me
just ask you a question if we find
something based on
science that is more true that's kind of
a new piece of knowledge
what you think that's because it's
conflicting with what we've been told
before that's going to erode trust it's
going to basically increase trust in
who's telling us that what should we
just ignore this new finding because you
know we don't want to um confuse the
public I mean for me I want to know the
truth that's what builds trust hiding it
from the public or telling a different
narrative creates more distrust I mean
it's so funny it harms The credibility
of nutritional science well if
nutritional science was based on good
studies then they wouldn't be harmed
because would be telling the truth the
Physicians committee for responsible
medicine the group advocating a
plant-based diet on Wednesday filed a
petition against the journal with the
Federal Trade Commission wow so you're
going to attack a research paper based
on your disagreement now you're going to
start involving the Federal Trade
Commission like this is like ridiculous
this is not science in science we want
to welcome opposing viewpoints we don't
want to silence the other side the
competition basically this is what they
said in the study it says the World
Health Organization International agency
uh for research on cancer has indicated
that consumption of red meat probably
carcinogenic to humans whereas process
meat is considered carcinogenic to
humans these recommendations are however
primarily based on observational studies
that are at high risk for confounding
and thus are limited in establishing
causal inferences nor do they report the
absolute magnitude of any possible
effects furthermore the organizations
that produce guidelines did not conduct
or assess rigorous systematic reviews of
the evidence were also Limited in
addressing conflicts of interest and did
not explicitly address population values
and preferences raising questions
regarding the adherence to guideline
standards for trustworthiness so in
other words this idea that red meat is a
probable cancer is based on information
that has conflict of interest which I've
already been through that research and
uh I'll share more of that down below
with some links so check this out our
analysis has several strengths we
conducted five separate rigorous
systematic reviews addressing both the
evidence and randomized trials and
observational studies regarding the
impact of unprocess red meat and process
meat on cardiovascular and cancer
outcomes and community values and
preferences regarding red meat and
processed meat consumption despite our
findings from our assessment of intake
studies versus dietary pattern studies
their conclusion is that unprocessed red
meat and processed meat are unlikely the
causal factor for adverse Health
outcomes I wanted to bring that up
because one of the things that the
tobacco industry used to do or started
to do which then the alra process food
companies are doing is putting down out
into your mind about what is good and
what is bad to keep everyone confused
and one definite thing about redme is to
put you doubts in your mind that that
could be bad for you and so here you are
avoiding it when really it's not based
on sound science at all just going
forward I'm going to predict that
they're going to continue this there's
going to be a lot of bad PR on how
unhealthy red meat is I mean it's really
important to look at the source of this
data that's being pushed out there who's
pushing it out there and who's really
going to benefit from people not eating
beef but red meat when it's a high
quality is very good for the heart
especially if you're not consuming with
it these grains and sugars and junk food
now if you enjoyed this video there's
another video talking about the best
meal for your arteries to keep your
arteries really clean if you haven't
seen that video which is very popular
I'll put that up right here check it
out